donc au programme tapis du gop à dabira
à ne pas oublier le livre de lecture la
cote à créon la routine et bien et m
en quelques minutes les élèves sont
habillés en fonction du temps qu'il fait
ça crée vraiment une autre ambiance un
autre monde que de rester à l'intérieur
en classe et on a tout ce qu'il faut
pour faire la classe dehors la sortie
comportent souvent une période de
lecture a fait que même en hiver il ya
la plupart en fait sont très
enthousiastes à sortir à l'extérieur
donc c'est très rare que j'ai vraiment
la réticence puissiez en oeuvre sont
contents les favorites et par la suite
j'ai fait de respirer sans le masquer le
qui est vraiment on avait oublié ce
concentré de avec l'âge fret je sens que
certaines personnes sont plus apaisée
d'être à l'extérieur ça diminue aussi
leur anxiété mais aussi ça c'est que
l'apprentissage
il est concret au lieu d'apprendre les
sortes d'armes et on les voit les armes
avec qui perce le bois pour tourner les
pages on peut pas utiliser nos gants et
quand il fait froid c'est sûr que c'est
mon rôle
s'il fait froid ou s'il pleut le groupe
de 6e année sort moins longtemps le
plein air c'est aussi une leçon
d'adaptation cette semaine on est rendu
au delà phone os et aux chaque jour je
me demande quelle activité se fait le
mieux à l'extérieur je les adapte de
cette façon là donc c'est faux toujours
la même heure ça les motive ou c'est
parce qu'ils savent c'est toujours la
même chose si les enseignants sont
inspirés par les expériences scandinaves
et par des programmes de plein air comme
celui de l'uqam la mise en pratique
exige de la souplesse et toute une
logistique
c'est une culture à développer parce que
dans certains pays on le voit ça se fait
de manière beaucoup plus importantes
qu'ici
moi je pense que ça c'est jouable dans
le milieu scolaire sans trop d'enjeu
alors que c'est après cette volonté
individuelle 10 itude commence à
démontrer les bienfaits de
l'enseignement en plein air évidemment
la qualité de l'air à l'extérieur on
n'est pas confiné gestion du stress ou
si ça c'est quand même assez largement
documenté avec des avec des tests avec
le niveau de cortisol par exemple madame
vanille ça nous prépare pour plus tard
pour pas qu'on soit toujours sur nos
consoles ou tablette tout ça pour pas
que
on en brune notre cerveau ça m'aide à me
libérer et bien sûr quand je reste dans
quand je reste à l'intérieur je suis un
peu plus distraits par tous les bruits
ces élèves sont déjà convaincus de
l'effet positif du plein air dans leur
réussite scolaire ici anne louise des
pâtes si radio canada montréal